alors noémie lvovsky tête une
réalisatrice en fait que pâques bien
bloqué c'est formidable c'est incroyable
alors elle est l'héroïne d'une histoire
dans l'histoire c'est votre soeur dans
le film elle est mariée avec un goal sur
un non juif et ils s'étripent sans arrêt
sur le fait de savoir s'il faut qu'ils
fassent circoncire l'enfant qui vont
avoir ensemble et alors il ya une scène
absolument génial c'est qu'à un moment
ils sont réconciliés et lui fait une
pipe sous les draps et lui il est là il
est allongé comme ça il fait c'est bon
le prépuce est là tu vas la tête de la
fille elle recommence à s'énerver c'est
vraiment drôle
c'est un team qui est très drôle mais
une vraie pipelette gestionnaire entendu
mais il a l'air d'avoir un sourire lui
alors au faîte charlotte qui était notre
invité récemment à refuser de répondre à
cette question votre votre fils belle
île circoncis ou pas oui mais voilà
pourquoi la refuser je sais pas oui les
circoncis je pense y oui comme son père
comme son père dans tous les cas
charlotte elle est radieuse dans ce film
elle et elle est épanouie et elle est
allée souriante elle et glamour
on l'a rarement vu à l'écran comme ça
c'est à dire pas torturé avec les
cheveux propres si vous avez fait ben en
fait moi j'en avais effectivement marre
de la voir comme ça au cinéma à la
maison elle a les cheveux propres ailes
et souriante elle est gentille et
j'avais envie j'avais envie de la voir
comme ça j'en ai marre qu'on qu'on
l'appelle à chaque fois qu'on a besoin
d'une causette au cinéma alors terrance
tempo parfait alors vous dites
évidemment si j'ai pris brad pitt à la
place de terrain du stade du ray pas eu
de film parce qu'on n'aurait pas compris
qu'elle se bat repas avec les
correctement
soucy termes simples et n'est pas mal
non qu'il ya des filles qui les vieux
voilà quand même quoi non c'est sûr que
si ça avait été un jeune gars beau etc
il n'y avait pas de film alors quand on
vous demande si autobiographique vous
dit que non évidemment vous ou c'est pas
vraiment autobiographique mais j'ai pris
des petites scènes comme ça de la vie
pour pour les mettre dans le film enfin
quand même charlotte nous raconter c'est
vous a raconté plein de trucs comme
charles elle nous a raconté que dans
love et cetera de marion vernoux iv
berling est temps qu'il y avait rien
entre berling et elle j'étais super
sentai berling via un coup après le
tournage avec lui et tout ça est que
apparemment une love affair entre
berling lg c'est quand même moins sympa
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai mais aussi
l'hymne est arrivé dans de faire un film
d'aller tourner un film à l'étranger de
rencontrer l'actrice avec qui je vais
avec qui je vais tourner et pas la
trouver si séduisante que ça et au
moment où les houles et où les scènes de
séduction et les scènes d'amour sont
arrivés
la gaule commence au cinéma on maîtrise
pas les érections c1 après sa non
désistement ici rien passer avait eu
main s'est rien passé mais j'aime
beaucoup par l'équipe
elle dit que pire quand bras c'est pire
que se retrouver au lit avec un mec
en fait c'est vrai c'est l'état d'amour
dans lequel on se met pour jouer l'amour
regard le regard et les dépenses et même
d'ailleurs un moment vraiment des
raisons flipper cela dit ça ici elle a
dit oui quand on joue l'amour d'ailleurs
il ya une scène dans votre cible qui
vachement bien c'est un moment vous
arrivé par hasard à londres elle est
dans la caravane avec terrain de tintin
on comprend bien qu'ils sont en train de
baiser on comprend bien qu un truc quoi
nos échecs le scénario même corde
non mais c'est sûr que quand on tourne
il ya des choses qui ce qu'il ya des
choses bizarres sur les tournages on a
une journée nos nuits ensemble oui on
oublie on oublie la maison quand même
sérieusement dans l'antre galles pour un
garçon sérieux c'est le terrible quand
même non comment on fait qu'est-ce qui
était régi bornes avec une gonzesse
toute la journée à poil dans un sac j'ai
écrit ce nom parce qu'on a été jaloux il
vend parce que tout d'un coup j'ai
réalisé ce qui se passait dans ma tête
comme walter visionner les [ __ ] qui
tourne avec ma femme ce qui m'est arrivé
de le forcer un peu la main à sa femme
dont il refuse un scénario qui me
faisait chier toi un homme en gênant
jamais et on lui a jamais demandé de
tourner non mais quand on est dans un
lit à poilley qu'une grossesse toute la
journée on bande non à on peut vendre
enfin ça peut arriver c'est de se dire
mais qu'est ce qui se passe alors après
l'attaqué qu'elle devient du
dans nos esprits la paix j'en profite
pas question d'aider qu'est-ce qui se
passe alors une seule question et après
on arrête quand on fait semblant de
baiser avec une gonzesse
bon on est sur l on fait semblant de
baisers au cinéma l'accueil on la met au
trou succession qu'est ce qu'on fait
est-ce que cela fait scotch et non on
peut se la faire scotché sur l'accueil
en a inscrit scotché sur la cuisse je
balancerai pas mais je connais un acteur
qui sait scotché sont maintenant on peut
s'apercevoir et cela se mettre entre les
cuisses bout d'un moment on joue sinon
bah je sais pas ça dépend où est la
caméra aussi quoi c'est vrai je sais pas
ou alors on est vraiment dont on fait
n'importe quoi un peu quand même à se
voit sinon ça dépend où la caméra mais a
priori la caméra et jamais
là où il faut vraiment sinon là mais
vraiment si l'accalmie 16c les films
pornos quand même qu'ils vont chercher
ça ouais mais non mais c'est aussi
l'état à l'amour c'est aussi dans la
tête donc
donc c'est sûr que ça peut devenir un
petit peu excitant et à la gêne y'a le
malaise est bon c'est assez bizarre est
ce qu il arrive qu on s'abandonne est
con et j'accuse vraiment là aussi j'ai
entendu parler de certaines histoires
mais je tairai soit le jeudi 14 mai un
peu court même si ça se passe pas là ça
favorise qui peut se passer après que ce
sont dix journées terminé on n'a peut
être pas forcément envie de rentrer tout
de suite les réjouit sous le poids d'une
bo peut-être pas lui payer un verre
après quoi non mais ça favorise la pré
tournage on est bien d'accord et votre
coupe résiste à tout ça depuis une
dizaine d'années une dizaine d'années
c'est fort quand même moi j'ai pas eu
tellement l'occase j'ai pas eu beaucoup
d'occases quand même j'espère que non ce
qui est terrible empêcha pas tourné avec
femmes au cinéma pour le copain de celui
qui se tape la balle mais moi je veux
pas vivant je vais pas vous refuser le
bourdon bon bah c'est vrai quand même
que vous avez rencontré charlotte
gainsbourg sur un tournage c'est vrai
donc si c'est arrivé une fois ça peut
arriver deux fois et bien qu'il soit
peut recommencer l'eau et bien sûr que
ça va commencer le chauffe pas trop
non j'ai pas trop de chauffer
mais
yvan attal on va essayer de mieux vous
connaître
alors vous êtes né en 1965 à tel aviv en
israël alors vos parents contrairement à
beaucoup d'autres
les pieds-noirs et au lieu de venir en
métropole en 62 quand l'algérie a été
indépendante
ils sont partis en israël pourquoi je
suppose qu'à l'époque il était sionistes
juifs d'algérie sont barrés ils ont été
en israël
et vous allez pas ouais vous avez été
conçu dans un kibboutz exactement
puisque conception collective
évidemment alors en fait nous parlons
ils restent pas longtemps là-bas parce
qu'en 67 quand vous avez deux ans il
rentre en france leur a pas plu même pas
deux ans je crois projeté tout petits
sont restés quatre cinq ans je crois
qu'à l'époque il y avait en fait
énormément de racisme entre sépharades
et ashkenazes on va dire entre ceux qui
ont fondé l'état d'israël et ils
viennent d'europe de l'est exactement et
les violences car il va y avait quand
même pas mal de racisme et du coup
j'étais pas si bien que ça en israël
donc ils viennent en france à créteil là
vous retrouver dans une hlm votre père
horloger et votre mère son boulot
c'était de s'occuper de vous ce qui
était un boulot à plein temps il faut
bien le dire
alors vous retournez de quelques fois
comme ça en israël après mais en fait
c'est quand vous tournez les patriots
avec rochant vous vous arriver un jour
dans une caserne qui avant était un
hôpital
et c'est là où vous avez dit c'est fou
vous avez votre mère a dit oui c'est là
qu'est née cette saison ont tourné dans
une matin j'arrive très très tôt dans
une dans une espèce de enfin s'était
transformé en caserne pour le film
c'était censé être des bureaux du mossad
et on me dit que c'était une clinique et
je suis dans cette ville où je suis né
d'ailleurs il faut et à côté tel-aviv et
à ce moment-là je me dis c'est que c'est
pas possible je puis il n'ya pas à ce
pas une grande ville et on me dit que
c'était un hôpital donc effectivement
j'ai appelé on m'a dit que c'était
l'endroit où j'étais c'était très
étrange reste étrange alors vocation
précoce cours de mise en scène des
lycées et rapidement vous découvrez
robert de niro dustin hoffman al pacino
votre modèle au cinéma c'est le parent
c'est pas forcément le parrain mais mais
quand j'y réfléchis je crois que c'est
un des films qui m'a vraiment donné
envie de faire du cinéma et même
aujourd'hui s'il ya un tas de films que
je peux revendiquer que j'aime
il est ressortie en dvd ça faisait
quelques
l'année on va dire que j'avais pas vu et
je suis resté scotché à nous alors quand
vous dites à nos parents yvan attal je
voulais faire du cinéma ils sont pas
inquiet parce qu'il existe de toute
façon il va se décourager 1
c'est vrai que j'étais assez gt gt à ses
grandeurs donc j'ai dit que je voulais
faire des cours de mise en scène j'ai
commencé à faire des courts pendant que
j'étais en terminale j'ai abandonné donc
ils sont dix salles exe chez en face
parce que ça les faisait chier ça les
inquiète et évidemment mon petit juif il
fallait que je fasse médecine ont en
tout cas des études je n'avais pas pu
faire et je paye mon bac donc je vais
dans un cours de théâtre
et puis et puis sont pas forcément
inquiéter mon père me forçais quand même
à venir au magasin changer les piles des
montres ouais vous avez à florent le
cours florent
deux échecs au conservatoire alors voulu
dire qu'aller tous les petits bruns
ouais j'ai l'impression en tout cas les
années où moi j'ai passé c'est que c'est
quand même des grands blonds qui était
retenu au conservatoire très a beaucoup
changé ma maman et puis les auditions
c'était bâclé le match il vous donne 10
secondes pour faire un truc c'était
assez atroce je me souviens même de la
rue blanche que que j'ai que j'ai foiré
ça a duré dix secondes j'ai dit roy a
répliqué j'ai entendu merci
ouais c'est fini quoi donc et au
conservatoire on va dire que ça a duré
dix secondes de plus vite et a priori on
arrive sur le plateau
mais pas besoin de moi ouais alors là
vous faites une pièce sur scène avec des
potes qui s'appelle biloxi blues de neil
saimone vous faites le rôle d'un d'un
juif intello avec des petites lunettes
rôle de composition et vous êtes repéré
effectivement par eric rochant qui vous
fait jouer un monde sans pitié avec
hippolyte girardot
il ya la fameuse phrase dont tout le
monde se souvient ce film génial un
monde sans pitié c'est un choc pour tout
le monde tu vas arrêter de faire la
moule au milieu du salon copie quand
même une phrase culte césar du meilleur
espoir masculin quand même dès le
premier film voit ses espoirs 1
ça va quand même et ensuite voilà
ensuite c'est vrai les deux films
suivants
ado c'est vrai c'est vrai ces deux
échecs après deux films de rechange 6e
aux jeux du monde avec charles
gainsbourg 1 et les patriots sa part
marche est ce un bon ça peut marcher
mais c'est dommage oui c'est un bon film
mais voilà c'est des années galères
ouais après un gros carton comme ça
c'est lancer les années galère parce que
parce que j'ai pas parce que j'ai
cherché aussi j'ai refusé des films j'ai
refusé des films en plus qui ont très
très bien marché donc je suis tombé dans
un camp fait on va plus envoyé beaucoup
de scénarios en fin de prêt donc donc
c'est devenu un peu la galère
là vous devenez un peu branleur à ce
moment là bas totalement dans leurs
choix et je foutais plus rien c'est vos
journées avec charlotte
non c'est vrai vous lever et ardent
c'est vrai oui oui c'est ça on a on est
encore mais c'était bien en même temps
je vous plantez un peu votre carrière
d'acteur ouais mais je fais je fais pas
exprès je me laisse un peu vivre en même
temps j'ai commencé à ces jeunes quand
même j'avais je sais pas quel âge avait
quand j'ai fait un monde sans pitié
quand quand on fait un film on prend un
bon petit chèque moi je n'étais pas
habitué à gagner autant d'argent
j'ai passé mon temps à claquer mon
argent plutôt qu'à l'ére faire des films
c'est ça me convenait complètement et
puis je me suis remis quand il n'y avait
plus d'argent avec le banquier très
simple finalement